what's up
you were able to go inside or well how'd
you find them I came around the back
side and I was like
just standing in our door I was like so
what the fuck's going on and he's like
the silver one going on yeah
[Music]
my headlights are shooting this way it's
all smoked and I was like
I was coming I was like
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right
your best approach from the back
again request
headquarters kind of support Ricks
they're getting FedEx here also
um
go inside
and he's like
[Music]
myself
one
all right
um
foreign
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
perfect Squad I have an EMP technology
available
good electric
ity
[Music]
Survivor
thank you
come back
[Music]
go back go back over there you go back
over there
what are you finding right because
they're still looking but it's not safe
your your uh your sister's gonna come
down from down the road okay all right
all right so just go back by that car
okay
when I came through here my headlights
were shooting this way it was all
smoking I was like yeah
cool
[Music]
um
everybody
[Music]